have you ever been in a Starbucks yes a
Starbucks is a multi-million dollar
business it's typically run by someone
who's 24 years old as in the individual
Starbucks shop yeah and they're on like
35 Grand a year so it's not that hard to
find someone who can run your business
you're not running Google you don't need
a chief operating officer you just need
someone who's like able to run a bank
branch or a call center or a McDonald's
here's the thing anyone who can run a
pub can run your business because a pub
has drunk people and people like hooking
up and having relationships a pub is
like razor thin margins you just do not
need to be running your business that's
not what you're good at as a key person
of influence you should be out there
doing the thing that only you can do